they are still battling to save homes on
evier
but in many parts of this island it is
not the professionals but the residents
doing the work
we watch from the village of gouvez as
men use their only tools
buckets of water to try to hold back the
flames
the people are right there alone
fighting the fire
alone with nobody people here are angry
they say little help came when far first
surrounded the village
and the threat still persists
the forest it's all burnt out the houses
likely were safe because people fought
for them
only people no nobody no fire department
nobody
nobody else resources here have been
stretched to the limit
in the neighboring village of olinica
volunteers helped firefighters try to
bring a major blaze
under control
[Music]
planes dumping water to try and stop the
path of destruction
but the fires have already forced the
evacuation of villages
hundreds escaping by boat over the
weekend from the port of pefkey
others have now taken refuge here at
this time of year you'd expect this
resort to be full of tourists
not now the only people on the beach are
those sleeping by the water for safety
and all the while aware of the toxic
cloud overhead
and some residents have now returned to
see what has happened to the places they
left behind
pablos garuffalo shows us the remains of
the home and business his parents built
up
over 40 years it's a lifetime
these are painful images and he chooses
not to show his face to the camera
i think a lot of people will leave the
area after this because
it's not just a small piece of forest
that is burned
is uh it's almost half the
the island who's gonna pay for all this
we we can't pay for sure
that is a question so many who've made
their lives on evia will be asking
so much has been destroyed here and so
much is still in jeopardy
the threat to this island and to greece
from the fars
is far from over michelle clifford sky
news evier